In the last video we talked
about ionization energy, or
the energy required to
remove an electron.
And we saw the general trend
in the periodic table, that
when you're in the bottom
left-hand side close to
cesium, cesium really wants
to give up electrons.
It's a big atom.
It only has one extra electron
in its sixth shell.
It can just give it up,
and then it'll have
five complete shells.
So it really wants to give it
away, so it requires very
little energy to ionize.
On the complete other side of
the spectrum, helium requires
a lot of energy to ionize.
It's very happy.
I has a full shell at
the first shell.
It's a very small atom.
The electrons are very
close to the protons.
So the coulomb force is
super-duper-duper strong.
So it takes a lot of energy
to remove that incremental
electron, and we learned that.
And the one thing I want to
cover before moving on to
other types of trends or
properties amongst the
different atoms is the idea of
a second ionization energy.
And I want to do this because
sometimes it's covered on some
chemistry exams or some
chemistry standardized tests.
And it's just the idea that
ionization energy is the
energy required to remove the
first electron, to go from a
neutral state to popping
one electron off of it.
The second ionization energy is,
then, the energy required
to remove the very
next electron.
And the reason why this is
interesting, is sometimes
they'll say, OK, what elements
have a very high second
ionization energy?
And your temptation would be,
OK, high ionization energy,
that also probably means high
second ionization energy.
And that might be true.
For example, neon has a very
high ionization energy, It
really wants to keep that 10th
electron, because it fills out
the second shell.
And then, of course, even if you
were able to remove that
electron, to remove the ninth
electron, when now its
configuration looks a
lot like fluorine,
that's still very difficult.
So you'd say its second
ionization energy
is still very high.
But if you think about it, the
elements with the highest
second ionization energies are
going to be some of the
elements with the lowest
ionization energy.
So, think about it.
And that might be kind
of confusing.
Lithium, for example.
Very low ionization energy.
It's got that extra electron.
It just wants to give it away.
But once it gives it away,
it's in a very stable
situation, Then its electron
configuration looks like helium.
So to remove that second
electron is
super-duper-duper difficult.
So lithium has a very high
second ionization energy.
And so you might run into a
question where they're like,
which of these elements has the
biggest difference between
their ionization energy and
their second ionization
energy, where their second
ionization energy is higher
than their ionization energy.
And lithium, or anything in
group one, that would be true,
because as soon as you remove
one electron, its electron
configuration becomes super
stable, so removing that
second one is super-duper
difficult.
And you also see this
in this chart.
This is, of course, the first
ionization energies.
But let's say, the case
with lithium, you
removed that electron.
It was very easy.
You only needed five electron
volts to do it.
But then your configuration
looks a lot like helium.
So that second ionization energy
is going to look a lot
like helium's first
ionization energy.
Anyway, I don't want to
confuse you too much.
But that's an interesting point
that might pop up every
now and then.
Now another property, which is
in a lot of ways, in my mind,
related is the idea of
electronegativity.
The concept came up
by Linus Pauling.
I always remember him.
He was a famous chemist. What
I always remember is that he
was famous for being convinced
that Vitamin C was kind of the
key to living forever.
And he would take huge
doses of Vitamin C.
I should probably read
up on that again.
I don't want to spread lies
about Linus Pauling.
But I remember reading that
when I was in high school.
But anyway, he came up with the
idea of electronegativity.
And the idea is that when two
atoms form covalent bonds--
and I haven't taught you what a
covalent bond is, and I was
planning on doing that in a
couple of videos from now--
but the idea of a covalent
bond is really just atoms
sharing electrons.
Let me draw that out.
So if I have oxygen, oxygen
looks something like this.
I could draw it like that.
I could also draw oxygen like
this, just because I'm going
to use these extra electrons
to bond.
And if you take oxygen like
that and you add it to two
hydrogens-- hydrogen
has one electron--
what's going to happen?
You might not know yet, if you
haven't seen a covalent bond.
But the atoms will actually
share electrons.
So this oxygen, you put
it in the center.
You have these, over here.
Let me draw it like that.
The electrons from oxygen
I'll do in green.
And then hydrogen, I'll just
do it in this orange color.
So we have two of
these hydrogens.
So one hydrogen will be there.
And then the other hydrogen
will be there.
Now what just happened?
Well if this hydrogen can
pretend that both of these
electrons, it has to kind
of share this green
one with the oxygen.
And the deal is, hey, I share
the green one and you let me
borrow the green one, and I'll
let you borrow the orange one,
we both can kind of feel like
we have a stable electron
configuration.
Hydrogen feels good because
the one s-shell
is completely filled.
Oxygen fills great because
it's valence shell is
completely filled with
eight electrons, two
of which are borrowed.
So it feels great.
This is a covalent
bond, where the
atoms are sharing electrons.
And so this sometimes will
be drawn like this.
Oxygen.
Those are the extra electron
pairs of oxygen.
And they'll just draw
a line like that.
And that line implicitly is
saying, look, there's two
atoms on either end.
There's the oxygen
electron there.
And then you have the hydrogen
And they're kind of shared.
These two things mean
the same thing.
But that line just means
a covalent bond.
Now my whole point behind
talking about covalent bonds a
little prematurely is so
that I can touch on
electronegativity.
And the idea that Linus Pauling
came up with is that
in these covalent bonds, the
sharing is not equal.
That some of the atoms
will hog the
electrons a little more.
So in this case, oxygen.
We learned about oxygen.
Oxygen is way over here.
It loves to grab electrons.
It has a very high ionization
energy.
It's only two away from having
an electron configuration
similar to neon and being
super-duper happy.
So oxygen loves electrons.
Hydrogen is a little
bit here or there.
It could gain an electron
and then it'll
have a stable 1s orbital.
Or it could lose an electron and
it will essentially just
turn into a positive ion.
It can go either way.
So it's a little bit more
ambivalent about what happens
relative to the electrons.
But oxygen really wants
the electrons so
that it can get completed.
So in this relationship between
oxygen and hydrogen,
oxygen is more electronegative.
It's more electronegative, which
means it kind of hogs
the electrons a little
bit more.
So if you were to draw this
relationship here, it might
look something-- If you were
to draw this bond.
This is all abstract.
Maybe you would draw
it a little bit
heavier on that side.
And this is not really at
all a convention, but I
just made that up.
Or if you just drew the hydrogen
and the oxygen part
of it, maybe the electrons
spend most of their time
around-- this is a probability
distribution-- and less of
their time around hydrogen.
And that would be true for
the other hydrogen.
They spend less of their time
around the hydrogen and a lot
more of their time around
the oxygen.
The idea of electronegativity is
just that one atom is going
to hog the electrons more when
you form a covalent bond.
Now if we wanted to figure out
the trend of electronegativity
on the periodic table, what do
you think's going to happen?
Which elements are likely
to hog electrons?
Well, the ones that
love electrons.
The ones that it's
very hard to take
electrons away from them.
The ones that are super-close
to completing a full eight
valence electrons in their
outermost shell.
So the most electronegative
atoms are
going to be right here.
They're going to be the
halogens, especially the
fluorine, because the small ones
want the electrons even
more because they're
a small atom.
The electrons are going to get
closer to the nucleus.
And the reason why I'm not
talking about the noble gases
here is because these don't
form covalent bonds.
They're always happy.
They're all these inert gases.
Inert just means that they
don't do anything.
A similar word is inertia.
Inertia means the tendency to
want to stay at rest, not do
anything, or stay in motion,
but I won't go
into that too much.
But these are inert.
They don't do anything.
So these guys react.
They form covalent
bonds up here.
And when they form covalent
bonds, they hog the atoms.
Likewise, when these guys down
here form covalent bonds,
they're like, you know what,
you can have the atoms. I
don't need them.
I'm actually happier without
them altogether.
In fact, sometimes these
guys actually just
give away the atom.
They don't even form
a covalent bond.
It's called an ionic bond.
We'll talk about that
in the next video.
But as you can see, the trend
is the same as it is for
ionization energy.
These guys, a lot of
energy required
to remove an electron.
That's because they
love electrons.
So these guys are also
very electronegative.
They're going to hog the
electrons in a covalent bond.
These guys, very low
ionization energy.
Very easy to take an electron
away from them.
And that's why they have very
low electronegativity.
They're very unlikely to hog
an electron in a bond.
Now the other trend that some
people sometimes talk about is
the metallic nature
of an element.
And so, there's a lot of things
that, in my mind, I
imagine when someone talks
about metallic nature, I
imagine it should conduct
electricity, it should be
shiny, it should be malleable.
I can bend it without
it cracking.
That's how I imagine
metallic nature.
But when people talk about it
in chemistry, they're really
just talking about
a willingness
to give away electrons.
That's metallic nature.
And that is important.
If you talk about something
that's going to conduct
electricity or be malleable or
have this sea of electrons
available that the
atoms can sit in.
But the same trend.
Which atoms are very likely
to give away electrons?
Well, the bottom left, right?
As you go down, the atom gets
bigger, so the electrons are
further away from the nucleus.
So the coulomb force is weaker,
so those electrons are
more weakly bound.
And also, if you just have one
extra electron here or two
extra electrons there in your
outermost shell, you're just
like, hey, let me get rid of
them and then I'll have a
complete outer shell.
So these guys want to
give away electrons.
So they have a very high
metallic nature.
These guys want to
keep electrons.
And they want to take more.
So they have a very low
metallic nature.
In fact these are completely
non-metallic in any way.
And if you were to say, within a
group, the trend-- I mean, I
did the diagonal, but that's in
general true-- is that the
further you go down a group,
the size of the atom is
increasing and the outer
electrons are
further from the nucleus.
So the electron force is going
to be weaker-- or the coulomb
force is going to be weaker.
So you're more likely to
give away electrons.
So your metallic nature will
increase as you go down.
And your metallic nature will
increase as you go to the
left, because when you only have
a couple of electrons in
your outermost shell, you
want to give them away.
So metallic nature, it goes
in the opposite direction.
It goes like that.
But for the same reason.
These guys love to
hog electrons.
give them away.
Right?
So ionization energy increased
to the top right.
Electronegativity increased
Metallic nature increased
to the bottom left.
The last trend we could talk
about is just atomic radius.
And there's a lot of different
ways to actually measure this.
And there's no one best way,
because obviously, we already
talked about it, an atom doesn't
have a fixed radius.
The electron could show up
pretty much anywhere.
So you could just kind of
do a hard boundary.
OK, 90% chance of finding
the electron.
That's your sphere
of the atom.
Or you could say, OK, if this
atom bonds with another atom,
what is half the distance
between the two nucleuses.
Right?
If you make a bond like that.
This is the distance between the
two nucleuses and then you
can say the atomic
radius is that.
So there's a lot of ways.
But I think you get
the general idea.
It's just the size
of the atom.
And you could already imagine
that as you go down any one
group, the size of the
atom increases.
You're adding on more and
more energy levels,
more and more shells.
The atom is just getting
larger and larger.
In fact, we've used that as an
argument as to why, as you go
down, ionization energy
goes down, or
electronegativity goes down.
So the atoms become larger
as you go down.
Now, the one thing that might
be a little un-intuitive is
what happens as you
go to the right?
You're adding electrons as you
go to the right, but you're
adding them all in the
same shell, right?
So if this is the nucleus, right
there, and you're in
some shell, some
orbital shell.
And obviously, they're
not all spheres.
But let's say you're in
some orbital shell.
As you go to the right in a
period, you just keep adding
electrons to that shell.
Right?
This is a super-gross
oversimplification.
And as you go to the right,
you have more
protons in the nucleus.
So this is only getting more and
more positively charged.
So what happens is that these
electrons get pulled inwards.
They get pulled inwards.
So as you move to
the right on the
periodic table, size decreases.
And then you say, OK, but
what about when you
go to the next period?
You're getting more
protons there.
Won't that decrease?
You are.
But at the same time, you're now
adding the electrons in a
new shell that's further
from them.
So it gets larger when you
go to the new period.
So electron size, as
you go down, large.
And as you go to the left,
you get larger.
So electron size goes from the
bottom right to the top left.
Although in general, the things
that are in a lower
period will have a larger size
than most things in a higher
period, regardless of
what group it's in.
But the general trend within a
group, the higher the number,
the larger the atom.
Within a period, the more
protons you have,
the smaller the atom.
Anyway, I hope you found
those interesting.
In the next few videos we'll
start with bonding.